you will be in beast mode for John wick
three opposite Keanu Reeves it's the
first time that they have ever worked
together but they almost did before
guest correspondent Ben Aaron got the
scoop
even though Holly could barely speak
after losing her voice have you guys
worked together in the past
no we almost did where I was offered
speed before said to Brooke I stupidly
said no stay on her job but in my
defense
when I read the script the bus didn't
leave the parking lot no no no no then I
see the movie in fast-forward 25 years
Allie pretty much begged director chads2
house key to get the butt kick in
leather wear and dog love and warrior
role opposite kyon OHS hired assassin in
John wick chapter 3 good to see you too
did you have to learn how to train dogs
I did I work with these dogs a lot so
that they could get to know me and I can
know them and I could command them on
the day and just sort of wrangle them a
little bit if things went crazy Holly's
been training for I don't know however
many months and stuff I get there the
trainer says to music don't look don't
look at them in the eye
great yeah no she was boss how much
training but you guys have to do in
order to learn these martial arts moves
and all that like I worked six months
probably almost five days a week and
training to three hours shows
[Music]
[Applause]